the clip we show you and Jason are the
scene is your characters are stranded in
the water for really at sea for a long
time what
how'd it take a long time to shoot that
or is it we we shot we only shot over
the course of two and a half days which
is not that's absurd it should be four
or five and so we were shooting really
long hours like we do think we were in a
tank we were in the ocean for a day and
then we were in the tank for a day and a
half and there was a I think a 14-hour
day where we were in the water the whole
time and it was the Caribbean so it was
nice but at night it does get a little
cold yeah I know you know so we put the
the wetsuits on bottom and in order to
stay warm often when you wear a wetsuit
you know where this is going you relieve
yourself and it feels yeah no I don't
tinkle tinkle were using medical
terminology I see I have a two year old
yeah so which but she doesn't say - she
says urine because she's you know sure
yeah she's mature and you she says I
need to go urinate you say you mean
tinkle everything's completely backwards
in here it really is it really actually
is so yeah Jason no we would go off to
our respective corners and just get a
little warm yeah
warm up that's disgusting but actually
quite common it's a very common practice
we won't warm you were warm Emily
there's a theme yeah you get cold a lot
yeah I called for a heater I didn't know
you want me to urinate all over the room
[Applause]
you